my teeth hurt my teeth hurt like my
teeth are tingling my lips are burning
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans coming at you
from the hot one set for a very special
event
i'm going to be taking on the pocky one
chip challenge and i'm going to be doing
it
with a very special guest but before we
introduce him
the pocky one chip challenge you've
probably heard about it it sweeps the
internet every year and in fact
four years ago i did this challenge
alongside my friends
emily oberg and nedesca and it was
without exaggeration one of the spiciest
craziest experiences i've ever had
this is a hot chip this is a very hot
chip
you look at it and you think oh it's
just a chip but it fools you it's made
with the carolina reaper
and as hot ones fans know the carolina
reaper is not to be messed with
but enough chit chat it is time to
introduce our guest
he is one of my favorite hot ones guests
of all time it is lil yachty
yachty welcome back to the hot ones
experience
i was so happy when i found out it was
you because i had such a good time at
our shoot
but i was also quite surprised because
you'd had hot sauce for the first time
at hot ones oh
how has your relationship with hot sauce
changed since that first hotline shoot
i haven't had it since then wow so this
will be your second time
experiencing this sort of inferno spice
yeah i wouldn't tell you like i
i had a long [ __ ] before i agreed to do
it
your hot ones episode it's a lot of our
fans favorite episode it was such a
unique experience seeing you eat hot
sauce for the first time
what was your experience of doing hot
ones you know i took that hot sauce home
and like it became a thing where you
couldn't come in my house
unless you tried the hot sauce because
people always thought i was like faking
it
oh my god my god
let's let the adventure begin and unbox
this thing pop this thing open see
what's going on inside the box
all right first up pulling out a hat
there you go
you look like justin timberlake i'll
take that i'll take that any day of the
week
all right here we have a towel very
practical to put a towel in for the
sweat we're gonna need it i know i might
need it and then uh we also have some
more bags of stuff here we have
zesty salsa verde chips haunted ghost
pepper chips and then finally we have
some fiery chili limon chips
do any of those look good to you yaddy
the zesty salsa verde chips that are the
least hot
seem the best for me i think that's good
for you too we also have
it's like kind of like uh a chain i
guess if
you're able to eat the pocky chip and
and last then i guess you get kind of a
gold medal here
yeah i think it's well deserved and then
finally
the coffin box yo bro what
here we go we have the pocky chip
right here it's about to go down i'm
starting to feel a little bit nervous
already oh my god
this is so crazy the pocky one chip
challenge champion and then he got some
rules so if you can go
five minutes without throwing in the
towel eating or drinking anything that's
feather weight if you go an hour plus
that's heavy weight
i am thinking i'm going to be in the
featherweight what
i'm told that you need gloves to handle
this thing
let's do it all right yachty are you
ready to dig in
and take on the pocky one chip challenge
no yo the box is literally saying
there's no turning back right i don't
often eat foods that come in a coffin
but there's no
turning back now ripping this thing open
this actually looks quite different from
the one that i had before
the chip is black what the [ __ ]
it has a sichuan peppercorn sort of
numbing thing
the carolina reaper thing that i'm
picking up on i mean look at this chip
bro this chip is so scary looking uh
i already know where this is going this
is such a bad idea
it smells so scary
i know and you know i know that you're
you're not exactly an adventurous eater
you know i know that you stay in your
lane
my stomach has dropped yeah i feel the
exactly i'm at the top of a roller
coaster ride
i know but we're in too deep we are in
too deep at this point
oh i feel like i'm about to perform at
the grammys or something
i'm so nervous me too
i felt like i feel like i'm probably
gonna have to cancel my entire day after
this
yeah you're gonna be out for a few hours
if i recall
if i remember this chip all right here
we are
there's no more avoiding the inevitable
i have this little three minute
hourglass i've got a bet with camera guy
bill who says that i can't let this
thing run out without taking some milk
or taking some water
yeah i'm not i i'm not on that
all right it's the time
it's the place and it's now fire in the
hole
down the hatch
different than the last one getting that
build
yadi how are you feeling
oh my god
oh i wish this was moving faster
oh [ __ ]
i think it's crazier than the show but
it is crazy
oh my god oh my god
the hottest in the world oh come on
come on i felt like i was boiling water
[Music]
oh
my stomach it feels like a cement mixer
just hot lava in it it's burning so bad
on a scale of one to ten how you doing
he's never been better he's never been
better
oh [ __ ] oh and
we're through
well there you have it another exciting
spicy food adventure with lil yachty
yachty before we get into an ice bath
how are you feeling
i can't i can't thank you lil yachty for
joining us
it is always a pleasure to see you my
friend
but my guess is it'll be a while
before you do something like this again
oh my ah [ __ ]
i don't blame you i don't blame you at
all
and for the people at home if you want
to do the pocky
one chip challenge make sure to use the
hashtag
hashtag onechip challenge on social to
catch up
on the spicy action and then of course
if you want to get it for yourself you
can pick up the one chip challenge at
paki.com or at participating retailers
i swear to god i didn't even know that
you could feel like this in life we'll
catch you next time
i need to
get out of here
is that frozen or no
i'm just thinking about life